[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat consacré ce soir au jumelage de
commune créée au lendemain de la seconde
guerre mondiale pour réconcilier les
peuples européens les rapprochements
entre communes se font désormais dans le
monde entier ici dans les yvelines
guyancourt et par exemple jumelée avec
comme et au bénin
d'autres partenariats apporte une
dimension plus symbolique la verrière
s'est tout récemment associé à khobar en
palestine nous en parlerons la fonction
des jumelages a donc beaucoup évolué à
quoi servait-il aujourd'hui
qu'apporte-t-il aux habitants des villes
concernées avec nous pour en parler
michel parent vous êtes adjointe aux
relations internationales et aux
jumelages de montigny le bretonneux
zoubida rafik vous êtes adjointe à la
jeunesse à l'emploi et au développement
économique de la verrière bonsoir
mesdames et michelbach et aux affaires
internationales
donnez moi ma présence voilà michel
parent montigny est jumelée avec civile
toutes situées en europe
pourquoi ce choix un peu traditionnelle
et bien c'est un choix c'est un choix de
la ville c'est un choix tout à fait
tout à fait qui me paraît tout à fait
normal parce que le but de nous si de la
construction européenne au départ
puisque nous avons nous sommes jumelés
premièrement avec l'allemagne c'est
petit et un jumelage très important et
symbolique en 1988
ensuite avec l'angleterre denton dans la
banlieue de manchester wicklow en
irlande
parce que si on se jumelle avec
l'angleterre une faute aussi se jumeler
avec l'irlande c'est mieux nous avons
aussi un jumelage avec l'omc a en
roumanie qui est un peu particulier mais
je pourrais en parler
absolument ensuite l'espagne san
fernando dans la baie de cadix et
marostica en italie voilà donc les
quatre langues principales qui sont
enseignés dans nos écoles sont
représentés dans ces jumelages voilà
sous vide à rafik du côté de la verrière
alors vous vous êtes vous êtes ouvert en
dehors des frontières européennes c'est
assez original
racontez-nous vos trois jumelages alors
le premier jumelage c'est avec la ville
de panique à halle en italie d'où en
fait cette année les trente ans en fait
la volonté de ce jumelage a été faite
par les habitants eux-mêmes italien de
la verrière qui souhaitait avoir une
colle collaboration un peu plus
importante avec la ville et leur pays
et c'est même eux qui ont choisi la
ville de panique à halle en italie donc
c'est intéressant c'est finalement une
jeudi à une population c'est lié à
l'immigration fête italienne
complètement la forte population
italienne qui à la verrière exactement
ensuite est venue la le jumelage avec le
mali la ville de diaby gay
là aussi c'est un ressortissant malien
qui habitant à la verrière qui a
souhaité aider sa ville son village et
comme vous le savez les les immigrés en
voit souvent les moyens financiers alors
à l'homme et à leurs familles village
pour les aider et souvent il se créé en
association et donc le secours populaire
à l'époque aidé énormément ces
associations là pour aider les familles
homo village en reparlera des mécanismes
à l'âge des sols pré mans et le dernier
le dernier jandari le dernier c'est tout
récent nous l'avons signé au mois de
février avec une ville de palestine
khobar voilà michel parent justement il
ya cette dimension humanitaire au niveau
des jumelages se sont pas seulement des
échanges scolaires vous avez vous aussi
eu un rôle là dedans avec la roumanie
natale
oui alors que la roumanie c'est
particulier c'est un tout petit village
luca qui a et qui a fait partie d'un
programme qui n'ait été proposée avant
même la chute de chercher ce qu en avril
donc 89 et à laquelle notre commune
adhéré immédiatement pour porter secours
à ce village qui était menacée donc nous
avons fait beaucoup pour ce village donc
en mesure en matière des deux scolaire
médical
nous avons aussi apporté le gaz et puis
construit une route entre le village et
un de ses hameaux et puis deux donc il
faut les y amener on vient à revendre à
l'intégration de l'ania
l'union européenne dans son dialecte
meinau lier des liens très profonds et
très amicaux très fraternel se sont
créés et ensuite la roumanie
la roumanie est hantée évolué peu à peu
nous avons pu construire d'autres biens
des liens culturels et nous avons pu
signer un véritable jumelage à ce moment
là zoubida rafik pourquoi vous vous avez
justement cherché à vous et à vous
associer avec des oui à s'ouvrir à vous
ouvrir à vous associer des villes hors
d'europe
et bien en fait c'est exactement la
représentation de la ville de la
verrière la verrière aujourd'hui contre
52 etc ni ce qui est ce qui est pas
anormal dans plusieurs villes on a
beaucoup de détenus et 52 c'est quand
même assez importants sur la ville de la
verrière
donc on avait cette volonté que nos
jumelage représente notre population
voilà donc qu'elle c'est bien parce que
vous les intéresser à ce jumelage à tous
les jumelages
ils sont très sains thèses souvent ça
vient d'eux comme je l'expliquais donc
pour pour panique à la l'instant mais le
mali c'est exactement la même chose
c'est venu d'un ressortissant malien qui
voulait aider sa famille etc et qui de
par nos actions personnelles
associatives
après la ville a voulu être un peu plus
impliqué dans ces échanges là d'où le
jumelage
après effectivement on a fait beaucoup
d'action avec le mali et pourquoi en
palestine
en fait il y avait une volonté il ya une
association l'association la jeep à
soissons paix juste israélo
palestiniennes pour une paix juste
israélo palestiniennes qui avaient qui
avait une délégation qui partait en 2013
et le maire à l'aja à l'époque nous
avait demandé de trouver un village ou
une ville qui correspondrait un petit
peu à la ville de la verrière
donc je faisais partie de cette
délégation en tant que membre de la jeep
et on a effectivement eu le
opportunité de trouver cette ville qui
correspondait à la ville de naissance de
marwan barghouti qui est citoyen
d'honneur de la ville de la verrière et
pourquoi c'est un vrai parti pris
politique quand même
alors bien sûr c'est un parti pris
politique parce que ce qu'on veut
montrer c'est que on est pour une paix
juste dans le au proche orient
ça c'est très important et que on est
aussi contre l'occupation israël
viennent ça c'est important et ça se
ressent dans la ville de la verrière des
habitants qui sont très au fait de tout
ce qui se passe au proche orient
et donc c'est important nous en tant
qu'élu de la vie le refléter exactement
ce pignon exactement cette opinion très
importante de nos concitoyens michel
parent de votre côté comment se sont
créés les différents jumelages en europe
et bien tout seul alors il s'était
pourtant engagé à 6 en fait ces
jumelages sont souvent partis de des
changes entre des professeurs parce que
notre but essentiel c'est de construire
l'europe ait une europe fraternelle à
partir de des échanges scolaires et
sportives par exemple des associations
sportives voilà donc cédé des
professeurs qui sont rentrés en contact
et ont compensé par exemple qui ont
commencé un échange et de cet échange
est né un jumelage s'est déjà c'était
déjà le cas pour l'allemagne c'était le
cas pour l'irlande pour l'angleterre
donc tous ces jumelages sont fondés sur
des rencontres entre des personnes qui
s'entendait bien qu'ils avaient envie de
monter des projets ensemble est servi
quand même aussi un idéal
nous avons un idéal européen est
nécessaire aujourd'hui justement de
maintenir quand même vrai que l'europe
salir acquis etc
malgré l'entente avec l'europe politique
attention mais c'est quand même
nécessaire de maintenir ce lien
fraternel entre les pays européens petit
c'est fondamental parce qu'en fait ce
qui n'est pas besoin d'aller ailleurs
l'umq à l'europe c'est que les gens ils
veulent quand on pense europe par
russell roussel c'est le travail de fond
de travail la base qu'ils comptent
mettre en relation
des familles mettre en relation donner
l'occasion à des jeunes des élèves qui
ne serait jamais partie de partir en
allemagne de découvrir à les amants
j'aime pas les allemands je n'aime pas
les anglais j'aime pas les italiens
oui ben finalement ils sont pas
tellement différents et sont alors ils
ont des ils ont des traditions
différentes mais ils sont tout à fait
tout aussi accueillants et voilà moi
c'est j'y crois beaucoup et beaucoup de
professeurs et de deux responsables
d'associations sportives et culturelles
y croient comme moi et c'est vraiment la
volonté de la ville
est-ce que ça a un coût graphique
combien ça coûte je me lâche à la ville
alors nous avons une association
qui gère les deux premiers jumelages en
subventions c'est à peu près entre c'est
à peu près de 1000 euros par an par an
voilà puisque à chaque fois les
associations font des actions pour
récolter de l'argent donc des ventes de
broderie on a déjà travailleurs sur
fêtes de la ville aux brocantes
voilà on s'autofinance justement pour
pouvoir faire nos actions
mais chez le parent de votre côté
j'imagine que les budgets plus
importants avec civile quand même avec
civile et puis c'est la volonté de la
commune nous avons un budget important
puisque nous subventionnons tous les
échanges scolaires il y en a beaucoup et
rien que voilà deux nous avons une
classe justement concrètement qu'est-ce
qu'on crespin alors voilà ce drame en g
nous avons un groupe de rugbymen
humaines des jeunes qui partent à huis
clos
bon voilà nous fonctionnons en partie
forcément nous aidons chaque voyage la
semaine prochaine nous avons une classe
de trente cinq élèves du lycée descartes
qui partent à sainte-feyre landrin
l'espagne ont là aussi d'une subvention
de 3600 euros pour pour toute la classe
et je précise que tous des élèves
partent tout le temps ça donne
l'opportunité ça donne l'occasion des
élèves qui ne serait jamais partie de
partir en voyage linguistique alors que
les vins et lors que les voyages
linguistiques souvent ne sont pas
accessibles à tout le monde
bon on a 2 juin nous envoyons une classe
de élémentaire à denton au mois de mai
en fait il ya une action de jumelage
tous les mois ou c'est toute l'année
donc c'est vraiment très concret c'est
très concret sous vide à rafik de votre
côté concrètement nous concrètement au
niveau des actions
pour donner par exemple exemple du mali
une des dernières actions c'était de
monter un projet pour éviter
l'assèchement d'une mare alors là on a
été beaucoup plus loin dans notre
financement puisque on a fait appel à
d'autres partenaires notamment l'iscid
donc là les là le département nous avons
à faire appel faire appel à
l'association secours populaire donc
tout le monde est aussi on a fait une
cagnotte internet parce que le budget
coûté 13 mille euros donc effectivement
là c'est plus qu'un jumelage c'est là on
pouvait pas toutes façons la ville ne
peut pas financer vu la perte enfin les
baisses de subventions c'est assez
conséquent mais on est arrivé donc
l'aménagement de la mare va avoir lieu
et justement c'est un des projets pour
éviter d'avoir lieu quant à quelle
échéance la balle a pour sa part été
très prochainement à l'arrêt pour cet
été d'accord qu'on a le financement donc
ses encours a très bien pour conclure
michel parent un mot si je suis
habitante de montigny comment je peux
bénéficier de ce jumelage alors mes
enfants vont être en échange mais
comment je peux en bénéficier c'est bien
vous inscrivez à l'association montigny
international qui est une association de
familles d'accueil sans laquelle nous
pourrons pas travailler nous travaillons
vraiment de manière étroite mais quitta
politique je précise et des gens de tous
bords enfin des gens qui aiment bien
qu'ils sont ouverts
voilà et vous est ce que les
associations montent il est
international et vous pourrez participer
à toutes nos actions
zahra fille de votre côté or nous c'est
là le comité de jumelage dans un premier
temps pour les deux premiers jumelages
pour diaby gay et panique halle et pour
khobar en palestine
c'est l'association addes gip qui porte
le projet las le jumelage avec la ville
de la verrière et donc si je vais des
renseignements je m'adresse à ces
associations là tout à fait complètement
très bien merci à toutes les deux
d'avoir participé c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission on se retrouve
dans quinze jours pour un prochain débat
merci à vous
[Musique]